podría ser un terremoto político para
honduras según las acusaciones de un
fiscal neoyorquino juan orlando
hernández presidente de honduras sería
cómplice aunque no ha sido acusado de
giovanni fuentes un narcotraficante
hondureño testigos del juicio contra
fuentes aseguran que el presidente ha
garantizado la protección del
narcotraficante contra sobornos y ha
facilitado el transporte de toneladas de
cocaína hacia estados unidos las
reacciones no se hicieron esperar
bueno lo que debe hacer es asumir su
responsabilidad creo yo como cualquier
otra persona como lo dicen aquí en este
país
[Música]
ellos vivientes
y el caribe el hermano era
en el poder desde 2014 hernández siempre
se ha presentado como un enemigo del
narcotráfico el lunes en twitter rechazó
las acusaciones
hablando de falsos testimonios y dio a
entender que si sicarios se aprovechan
de eso para reducir sus condenas podrían
dañar la cooperación internacional en la
lucha contra el narcotráfico mantendré
alianza internacional en la lucha anti
narcotráfico hasta mi último día de
presidente el 27 de enero de 2022 pero
sin arcos con llave mágica de mentiras
ganan beneficios de eeuu por falsos
testimonios la alianza internacional
colapsaría con honduras luego con varios
países
semanas después de destinar 4000
millones de dólares en ayuda
estadounidense a centroamérica la
administración baiden está afinando sus
planes y limitando drásticamente la
cantidad de dinero que se destinará
directamente a los gobiernos de honduras
el salvador y guatemala las ayudas
estarán sujetas a condiciones estrictas
basadas en medidas de esfuerzos
anticorrupción y buen gobierno